Hi, my name is Sean Fredella.
If you don't know me, I hope
you never meet somebody like me again.
That's because I've survived cancer
four times.
Four times over the course of
seven and a half years.
I've had Leukemia,
a bone marrow transplant,
chemo,
radiation.
I've had a craniotomy,
which is basically a fancy term
that doctors use
for cutting my head open
from this ear to this ear,
pulling down my face,
then use a drill to pull out the tumor
the size of a golf ball.
Yeah, fifth grade was not very fun.
I had many memories of cancer.
Some good, some bad.
I remember my family visiting me,
cousins, all my aunts and uncles,
having good times,
watching movies, pulling all-nighters,
maybe being the most competitive
bingo player ever.
But some of my most memorable
moments were with steroids.
Now, when I say steroids, most people
think of steroids like Barry Bonds,
get ripped, muscular,
or like Lance Armstrong,
or every single biker ever.
No, I had a different type,
and to put it lightly, this steroid
made me angry.
I was mad all the time and I complained
about just about everything.
I had the temper of 1,000 Donald Trumps.
Now, one time during Lent,
after church, I was walking outside
and an old lady started to approach me,
and she was shaking.
She was more nervous
than me giving a speech right now.
And she said, "Now Sean, what
are you giving up for Lent this year?"
I looked her straight in the eyes
and I said,
"Duh, my hair."
Now, all jokes aside, cancer was
a challenge for me.
I remember being held down
by four to five nurses,
getting needles in my chest,
which is, by the way,
way scarier than public speaking.
And I met lots of friends.
We fought with each other
and most of my friends didn't make it.
One of my friend's name was Tyler.
One day, my dad took Tyler and me
to go see a movie.
Tyler was 14 years old
and he just had a relapse.
Tyler said to my dad,
"Mr. Fredella, all I want to do
is drive a car."
Tyler passed away on March 15, 2012.
He was 14 years old.
He was never able to drive a car.
It's moments like these
and people like Tyler
that make me wonder why.
Why me?
Out of all my friends, why did I survive?
There has to be a reason.
And I think I know an answer,
and I'd like to share it with you.
I believe it's my purpose
to raise awareness
about the money allocated
to pediatric cancer research.
You know, out of all the money raised,
the millions, billions of dollars
raised to fight all cancers,
pediatric cancer only gets 4%.
Kids like you,
kids like me,
and kids like Tyler,
and it's only 4%.
Children die every day from cancer,
and they did nothing to deserve it.
We need to fight.
We need to make a change.
We need to have more than four.
And I think I can fix it,
I think I have a solution.
Well, here it goes.
Ladies and gentlemen, sports!
In America, we worship the athletes
who walk the hardwood courts
and awesome fields.
We wear Jordans because they wear Jordans.
We buy jerseys with their names on them
because we want to be like them.
Now, when you look at this picture,
what do you notice?
What stands out?
Now does anyone know what pink stands for?
When October rolls around,
the whole sports world is painted pink.
Everyone comes together
for a great cause and a great message
that helps breast cancer survivors
and patients fight breast cancer.
Now, just like breast cancer
uses pink as their color,
we could use gold, which is the color
for pediatric cancer awareness.
Gold on gloves,
gold on cleats,
gold on clothes.
We can fight pediatric cancer.
I can see it now.
It's the first Sunday of the NFL season.
100,000 fans chanting,
anticipating a great kick-off.
And out of the tunnels,
out of the corners of the stadium,
a blur of gold streaks across the field.
Thousands of fans chanting,
and the gold gloves and cleats
glisten in the Sunday morning sun.
All players from different places
with different dreams and different homes
come together for one cause
and one color - gold.
We need to fight pedatric cancer,
and I believe that
this is the way to do it.
From peewee to professional,
from kickers to coaches,
from goalies to guards,
everyone can wear gold in September.
My goal is that by this time next year,
everybody knows that September
is the month for raising awareness
for childhood cancer research,
and that gold is the color
for finding a cure for childhood cancer.
Now, don't take my word for it.
Who am I? Just a random kid
from Mountain Brook, Alabama.
Why don't you take the number three
pick in the 2016 NFL draft
Joey Bosa's word for it.
I'm Joey Bosa former defensive end
at the Ohio State University
and I believe our children
deserve more than four.
And why don't you take defensive lineman
from Iowa State University
Mitchell Myers's word for it.
Hi, my name is Mitchell Myers.
I play football at Iowa State University,
and I'm a cancer survivor.
Our kids deserve more than four.
And, since we're in New York,
why don't you take arguably the greatest
New York Yankees' pitcher ever,
Andy Pettitte.
Hi, this Andy Pettitte,
former pitcher of the New York Yankees
and Houston Astros.
Our kids deserve more than four.
Hi. My name is Sean Fredella.
Tyler deserves more than four.
Sebastian deserves more than four.
Andrew deserves more than four.
We deserve more than four.
Thank you.